Salut julien ça va? Ah tu m' piques mon texte maintenant bon dit non tu as déjà eu les couilles bleus toi aubin
Vas-y c'est bon il y a pas de honte ok alors une fois une soirée déguisée j'ai
NON !
je veux pas savoir enfaite
Aujourd'hui dans DTC, on va parler de testicules et que vous en possédez
personnellement ou pas, je vous conseille de rester parce que dans tous les cas ça vous concerne et non seulement ça vous concerne
mais ça devrait vous intéresser parmi les mythes et légendes sur le corps humain il en est un qui traverse les âges et qui sert
de moyen de pression voire de chantage depuis des générations
le mythe des couilles bleues
Alors pour celles et ceux qui n'auraient jamais entendu parler que dit cette légende les couilles bleu
blue balls dans la langue de britney spears
c'est quoi et bien une vieille croyance raconte que lorsqu'un homme est excitée sexuellement et que ça ne débouche pas sur une éjaculation
ses testicules prennent une couleur bleutée et deviennent
extrêmement douloureuse ce qui lui fait courir un grave danger pour sa santé alors autant lever le voile tout de suite sur ce mystère
C'est la vérité
mais en partie seulement donc rester jusqu'au bout je vais pas tout spoiler tout de suite
commençons par la douleur effectivement après une excitation sexuelle prolongée si ça ne se passe pas comme espéré
ça fait mal et je ne parle pas que de l'égo masculin mal placé
je parle des couilles aussi croyez moi sur parole
c'est la vérité comme bien souvent dans ce genre de cas de figure à la frontière entre l'embarras du quotidien est un réel problème médical
rien n'a été véritablement démontré par des études scientifiques en bonne et due forme mais sous la pression populaire
quelques spécialistes ont tenté d'y voir plus clair et ont émis des hypothèses
voici leur histoire
bon une érection vous savez comment ça marche
Bon en gros
mécaniquement on a une érection quand les deux corps caverneux qui sont situées de chaque côté du pénis se gorgent de sang ce qui
rigidifie l'ensemble
Dans ces cas là les vaisseaux chargés
d'approvisionner la zone en sang se dilate et pour empêcher le tout de retomber les vaisseaux chargés d'évacuer la zone se contracte
pour tout bien garder à l'intérieur et ça concerne les vaisseaux qui irriguent tout le secteur y compris les testicules après l'éjaculation
l'ensemble se relâchent et tout le monde rentre chez soi mais si l'éjaculation n'intervient pas
bon bah l'érection elle, elle comprend que c'est pas le moment donc elle disparaît mais tout le reste de la zone reste
congestionné notamment au niveau de l'épididyme
*musique
alors l'épididyme c'est un petit tuyau qui est replié sur lui-même qui s'étale sur une partie des testicules et à l'intérieur duquel les cellules spermatiques
font leur petit bonhomme de chemin et il semblerait que cet organe souffrent tout
particulièrement de la congestion puisque dans ces cas là on parle d'hypertension
de l'épididyme et ce serait ça qui donne cette lourdeur et ses douleurs au niveau des testicules
alors ça c'est pour la version la plus sérieuse qui a été décrite en l'an 2000 par des médecins dans une revue pédiatrique
oui je sais c'est chelou d'autres hypothèses
pas forcément incompatible avec la première avance que les vésicules séminales et la prostate pourrait aussi être en cause
les premières stock un liquide qu'on appelle le liquide séminal
quel éjectent au moment de l'éjaculation et qui va se mélanger aux autres liquides qui forment le sperme
oui le sperme c'est une sorte de cocktail
On en reparlera une autre fois si vous voulez
Parmi ces lui qu'il ya aussi le liquide prostatique qui est produit par
par ... la prostate ! la prostate c'est oui
ces deux organes pourrait être disons
contrarié d'avoir bossé pour rien ce qui accentuerait la sensation de tension et de lourdeurs et par contrarier j'entends
engorgé si vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais attention la prostate et les vésicules séminales elle se situe pas dans les testicules
pas loin ok mais pas dedans donc bon
et puis là encore il ne s'agit que d'une hypothèse non vérifier scientifiquement
bon donc on a vu le côté couilles mais le côté bleu alors
certains médecins avance une hypothèse selon laquelle du sang pauvre en oxygène
stagnerait dans les tissus et les colorés en bleu
savez comme la bouche des gens quand ils respirent pas bien bon là pour le coup c'est probablement plutôt de l'ordre du folklore
mais je vous le donne quand même mon observation personnelle ne m'a jamais permis d'observer ce phénomène coloré
mais bon en même temps je suis daltonien
alors si à vous ça vous est arrivé ou si vous avez constaté le phénomène n'hésitez pas à nous raconter ça dans les commentaires
par contre les photos c'est pas la peine pour être complet on va dire aussi que sans surprise y aurait aussi une dimension
psychologique à tout ça a base de fierté de frustration
oui c'est frustrant c'est vrai
attention ça veut pas dire que la douleur existe pas mais ça peut amplifier la façon dont elle est ressentie
Et c'est là qu'on en arrive au dernier point et pas des moindres les couilles bleus sont souvent brandie comme une menace
Quelle image mentale et chelou mais je m'explique je veux parler du chantage du type
Tu peut pas me laisser comme ça c'est hyper dangereux, mes couilles bleues peuvent exploser a tout moments
Alors soyons très clairs tous les hommes ne sont pas concernés par le phénomène
il y en a qui vivent ça très bien sans aucune douleur et pour ceux qui connaissent c'est pas forcément a se les cogner dans une porte non plus
pendant des jours en tout cas ensuite les couilles bleus ça n'est pas du tout dangereux pour la santé
c'est juste désagréable au pire
très désagréable des fois mais pas dangereux et puis surtout
des solutions existent il ya un traitement gratuit très simple d'utilisation
et plutôt pas désagréable il s'agit tout simplement de provoquer une éjaculation
et tout rentre dans l'ordre et a priori se provoquer une éjaculation les gens savent faire tout seul
après si vous voulez aider pas de problème mais ne vous sentez pas coupable et ne vous sentez pas obligés
D'ailleurs il me semble important de porter un fait à votre connaissance
nous de faire un petit rappel au moins ça fait jamais de mal le clitoris aussi à des érections
avec le même mécanisme que pour le pénis à base de sang qui afflue dans la zone et tout et du coup
pour les mêmes raisons la vulve bleu ça existe aussi
mais bizarrement on en parle beaucoup moins sa as peut-être un lien avec le fait qu'on a longtemps considéré qu'un rapport sexuel
ça prend fin avec l'orgasme masculin et que l'orgasme féminin hein pfff
Je vous laisse heuuu
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là mais prenez soin de vos organes génitaux et de ceux des autres 'fin si ils vous le demandez et si vous avez envie hein bien sûr
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
*Générique*